vamos con el problema número 10 el
problema número 10 dice que en una
cierta clase de niños y niñas se va a
elegir un estudiante al azar para leer y
lo que queremos es la probabilidad de
que un niño lea queremos la probabilidad
de elegir elegir un niño un niño sale
bueno vamos a suponer claro que cada
estudiante lo elegimos con la misma
probabilidad y que todos los niños saben
leer vale bueno las dos opciones de
información que tenemos es 1 1 saber que
dos terceras partes de los estudiantes
son niños dos terceras partes
son niños son niños pues esto es
suficiente verdad si sabemos que dos
terceras partes de los estudiantes son
niños entonces el 66 puntos 66 por
ciento de ellos
si quieres periódico entonces son niños
y entonces la probabilidad de que lea un
niño pues es de estar acá y está sobre
100 o bien dos tercios y lo piezas como
un número entre 0 y 1 entonces la
información del inciso 1 es suficiente
para responder la pregunta vamos a ver
qué nos dice el inciso 2 y el inciso 2
nos dice que en la clase hay 10 niñas
hay 10 niñas niñas
en la clase en la clase bueno pues esto
de aquí no nos da mucha información
verdad si únicamente sabemos que hay 10
niñas en la clase podría haber 0 niños y
entonces la probabilidad sería 0 o bien
podría haber 10 niños y la probabilidad
sería un medio entonces el inciso 2 por
sí mismo no nos resuelve no nos resuelve
la pregunta y de esta forma la respuesta
sería ah eso quiere decir que el primer
inciso nos ayuda para resolver la
pregunta pero el segundo por sí mismo no
es suficiente vale bueno vamos al
problema número 11 déjame cambiar de
colores para hacer esto un poco más
variada cuba- bueno en el problema
número 11 nos dicen que 5x 3 + 3g es
igual a 17 y lo que nos piden determinar
es el valor de x cuál es el valor de x y
las opciones son 1 saber que x es un
entero positivo x es entero positiva
entero positivo que creo que no sirve de
mucho verdad o sea si x es entero
positivo puede tomar pues cualquier
valor entonces pues no podemos
determinar el valor de x incluso bajo
esta condición podemos poner el entero
positivo que queramos y luego poner el
valor de que funcione porque ya no tiene
restricciones va entonces ésta por sí
misma no es suficiente le voy a poner
que no es suficiente por sí misma no es
suficiente y ahora vamos con el inciso 2
el inciso 2 dice y es igual a 4 x es
igual a 4
y yo digo que este de aquí si es
suficiente si tuviéramos el valor de
llegó si supiéramos esto entonces
podríamos poner aquí en vez de 4x vale y
de ahí podríamos despejar x en realidad
durante el examen no tenemos que hacerlo
pero ahorita lo voy a hacer porque
tenemos tiempo y paciencia y todo eso
entonces déjame encontrar el valor de x
vale entonces si es igual a 4x tenemos
que 5x + 3 veces 4x
4x eso que es un poco feo es igual a 17
entonces 5 x más 3 por 4 es 12 más 12 x
es igual a 17 de donde 17 x es igual a
17 y eso quiere decir que x es igual a 1
entonces con esta información podemos
determinar el valor de x vale entonces
el inciso 2 si nos da la información
suficiente para determinar el valor de x
y por lo tanto la respuesta sería b pero
una vez más durante el examen no tienes
que determinar el valor de x si no nada
más tener esta corazonada o bien
convencerte a ti mismo de que esta
información es suficiente para
determinar x vale bueno vamos al
problema al problema número 12 12 el
problema 12 nos pregunta si el producto
jota klm no más bien jk mn jk m m es
igual a 1
ok y la información que nos dan en el
inciso 1 es jk / m n
jk / m n es igual a 1 bueno pues esto
nos dice gran cosa verdad multiplicando
por n por mn tenemos que jk es igual a
mn entonces simplemente este cachito es
igual a este cachito pero de ahí no
podemos determinar que el producto sea
igual a 1 o no vale entonces este de
aquí no es suficiente le voy a poner una
tacha de que no es suficiente vamos a
ver qué pasa con el 2 en el 2 nos dicen
que jota es igual a 1 entre acá
j es igual a 1 entre acá y que me es
igual y que m es igual a 1 entre n creo
que esto nos da un poco más de
información a ver trabajando algebraica
mente este nos dice que jk es igual a 1
y éste nos dice que m n es igual a 1 y
eso está súper padre porque si jk es 1
entonces este cachito es 1 y mn es 1
este es uno y entonces el producto es 1
y por lo tanto con la información del 2
podemos responder esta pregunta va
entonces la respuesta sería ve la
información de 2 es suficiente pero la
información del primero no es suficiente
va bueno vamos al problema número 13
problema número 13 que voy a poner en
este color morado ok en el problema
número 13 nos dicen que en una cierta
estación de metro las salidas jk l&m
están en ese orden entonces déjame
dibujar así la estación de metro supongo
que esto será un problema de números en
la línea recta o algo así entonces por
aquí tenemos las salidas
j k l m j k l y m muy bien entonces lo
que nos piden determinar es la distancia
la distancia de acá a l queremos
determinar la distancia de acá a l
entonces queremos determinar esta
distancia de acá y como opciones tenemos
de información número uno saber que la
distancia de jl es 21 de jl es 21 21
kilómetros y bueno eso no nos permite
determinar acá en la verdad únicamente
nos dice que la capa que es 21 pero no
nos dice nada de dónde está acá entonces
pues eso no nos dice nada pues de esta
distancia que queremos determinar
entonces la 1 por sí mismo no es
suficiente
estar acá no es suficiente por sí misma
vamos a ver qué nos dice el inciso 2 el
inciso 2 nos dice nos dice que de acá a
m que la distancia de cada m es 26 26
kilómetros 26 kilómetros o sea que esta
de acá
de acá a m es de 26 ok está por sí misma
tampoco sirve de verdad así solita no
sirve porque una vez más si sabemos que
de cada ms 26 pues ahora no sabemos
dónde está l pero incluso juntando ambas
no tenemos suficiente información para
encontrar esto de aquí porque observa
cada osea si fijamos j y l cada podría
estar muy pegadita jo tal como por acá
en cuyo caso m tendría que recorrerse
para que si mira esto 26 verdad pero
entonces pues la distancia de cada l
sería grande o bien que podría estar acá
y m tendría que irse como está por acá
vale y entonces la distancia de acá a él
sería muy cortita en realidad estas dos
informaciones juntas no nos dicen cómo
es acá con respecto a él va entonces
aquí la respuesta es deja tomo el color
azul la respuesta es que ni siquiera
juntando ambos pedazos de información
podemos determinar la respuesta vale
bueno o sea la respuesta de esta
pregunta bueno vamos ahora con el
problema 14 en el problema 14
simplemente nos piden determinar si él
pero acá es primo
entero k es primo primo
y de opciones nos dan 11 que 2 k sea
igual a 62 casi igual a 6 y 2 nos dan de
opción 2 que uno sea menor que acá sea
menor que 6 bueno el primero pues
claramente nos debería de decir si k es
primo 1 porque de aquí podemos despejar
acá ahorita lo puedo hacer pero no
tendríamos que hacerlo salen simplemente
esta igualdad nos permite determinar acá
y eso nos permite responder la pregunta
pero bueno haciéndolo pues tendríamos
que dividir entre dos de ambos lados
entonces nos quedaría que acá es igual a
3 y entonces podemos responder esta
pregunta si cada es primo entonces estoy
aquí es suficiente para responder la
pregunta y el inciso 2 nos dice que acá
está entre 1 y 6 incluso aunque sepamos
que acá es entero pues todavía hay
varias posibilidades para acá que podría
ser 2 cómo podría hacer 345 entonces
pues si es 2 3 o 5 es primo pero si es 4
pues no sabemos o sea no es primo
entonces esta información no nos permite
determinar si k es primo o no
al menos no por sí misma sale entonces
aquí la respuesta sería a a el inciso 1
nos da la respuesta pero el 2 pues no
por sí mismo no y finalmente en este
vídeo en color naranja vamos a hacer el
problema número 15 para el problema
número 15 necesito una figura que me
parece que es un plano x y xi es un plan
x entonces lo voy a pintar por acá está
el eje x está el eje y los voy a
etiquetar existe el eje x el eje
además nos marcan por aquí el origen que
por aquí está el 1 que por aquí esté el
1 y además los cuadrantes están
numerados con números romanos el
cuadrante 1 el cuadrante 2 el cuadrante
3 y el cuadrante 4 vale bueno entonces
con esta figura nos hacen la siguiente
pregunta si sabemos que a b es distinto
de 0 si sabemos qué ave es distinto de 0
entonces en qué cuadrante nos viene el
cuadrante cuadrante de un cierto punto b
vale voy a voy a hacer un poco más de
espacio
entonces nos piden el cuadrante de ave y
para determinar eso nos dan pues estas
posibilidades de información la primera
posibilidad es saber que vea vea está en
el cuadrante 4
cuadrante
en el cuadrante 4 okay déjame pensar
esto un poquito recuerda que lo estoy
haciendo aquí improvisando vale en vigo
creo que estoy problema está más
interesante es ha de ser más interesante
de los que hemos hecho porque ver esto
está padre lo que nos dicen es donde
estaba y queremos saber en qué cuadrante
esta ave y bueno no sea queremos ver si
la información que vea esté en cierto
cuadrante es suficiente pero qué quiere
decir que un punto esté en el cuadrante
4 o sea que un punto viva en este en
este cuadrante de acá digamos un punto
equis y bueno pues eso quiere decir que
su coordenada x es positiva
o sea que x es mayor que 0 y que y que
su coordenada ye es negativa que es
menor que cero sale entonces pues aquí
el papel de la equis la joven lo juega
al ave y el del aire lo juega la
entonces saber esta información que ve
que vea está en el cuadrante 4 nos dice
que ven que ve es mayor que 0
es menor que cero
a es menor que cero vale pero sabiendo
que v es mayor que cero y que a es menor
que cero pues podemos determinar en qué
cuadrante está a b porque entonces
sabemos ahora que la coordenada x es
menor que cero porque a es menor que
cero y que la coordenada es mayor que
cero la coordenada es mayor que cero
porque b es mayor que cero sale y que
sucede o dónde están esos puntos pues x
tiene que ser menor que cero y ya tiene
que ser mayor que cero entonces tiene
que estar por acá está en el cuadrante 2
entonces a partir de esta información
podemos concluir que ave está en el
cuadrante 2 van entonces esto estuvo
súper padre con esta información si
pudimos determinar en qué cuadrante está
y con el link y en el inciso número 2 lo
que nos dan lo que nos dan de
información ahora es que coma menos ven
a coma menos b está en el cuadrante
número 3 en el cuadrante
y bueno así a simple vista pues o sea
podemos podemos determinar que esto nos
permite responder dónde está
es más o menos la misma idea de lo que
hicimos aquí arriba pero bueno vamos a
hacerlo para ver cómo se hace vale
entonces pues otra vez o sea ahora
tenemos que estar en el cuadrante 3 en
el cuadrante 3 pues cumple que está por
acá en este cuadrante tenemos tenemos
que x es negativa x es menor que cero y
que ya es negativa también que ya es
negativa entonces esta información nos
dice básicamente que es menor que cero y
que menos b es menor que cero
multiplicando por menos uno esta
desigualdad cambia de signo y nos queda
que b es mayor que cero y con esta
información pues ya podemos determinar
en qué cuadrante está de hecho es esta
misma información ve mayor que 0 a menor
que cero entonces con esto podemos
determinar que está en el cuadrante
muy bien entonces este por sí mismo
también nos permite determinar en qué
cuadrante estamos va pero ojo hay una
cosa que no he aclarado y es porque
aprobé es distinto de cero y bueno a por
ver es distinto de cero lo que nos dice
es que ni a nivel son se va y sin ya
nivel son cero eso lo que quiere decir
es que a como ven no está sobre los ejes
porque esos son los puntos en los cuales
v es igual a cero vale bueno le voy a
dejar hasta aquí en este vídeo seguimos
con el problema 16 en el siguiente